we're at an old firemen hose and I'm
near Munich today it's packed full of
vintage car models there's a showroom in
the old barn and the cars on show here
range from Jaguars to Porsches and
Mercedes all of them are for sale on our
mission Monda doesn't just love vintage
cars
he loves trading them he thinks this
Fiat Dino Spyder is a very classy model
it was unveiled for the first time at
the 1966 Turin car show and the car has
been completely restored it's as good as
new
so to speak its body is in great Nick
it's colored a zero
the typical Fiat blue both its design
and form are exquisite the headlights
are slightly hidden its fenders are
wonderfully designed it has a pretty
sexy look and feel and it comes with
Fiat Dino first edition Center lock
wheels back in the day Fiat made
Ferraris that everyone could afford and
the Dino's engine is made by Ferrari in
the mid 1960s Enzo Ferrari designed a
new formula 2 car he took the engine for
it off the shelf but formula 2 rules
specified that engines had to be from an
addition that been produced at least 500
times to comply Ferrari decided to fit
its unit into a Fiat car and that's how
the Dino was born
beshal mnDOT's piadina wasn't for sale
until just recently that's because it's
his but now Michelle is ready to part
company being a dealer he's got a few
other cars
Mishael is taking this collector's item
for a test drive for the last time he
wants to make sure his Dino doesn't fall
to bits when the buyers turn up he has
had a chance to collect some of the
prettiest and most expensive vintage
cars around but this Dino Spyder is one
of his favorites
it came from America but Mishael picked
it up a couple of years ago in Europe
what he likes best about this Fiat is
that it races out of the blocks in votes
160 horsepower as body is really nicely
done in his opinion its form was
designed by Pininfarina a really classy
car it has Flair and a bit of a vintage
feel and once it's up and running
Dino proves it could still match it with
the best of them now it's up and running
he can really put his foot on the gas
it's only now that you sense what the
Dino can do it's most fun driving at top
speed and delivers pure driving pleasure
in the mid-60s this Ferrari v6 engine
was better than both Mercedes sl6
Michele says it has more of and can
accelerate better than either of them
but watch out when you're driving at
high speeds the rear suspension is a
live axle which does make taking corners
difficult for him the most important
thing is developing a feel for the car
still double shock absorbers and extra
power make the Dino a pretty manageable
drive with a pretty high threshold
despite that rear axle the best thing
about the interior is that it's
completely intact and unrestored Michele
says there are these cool imitation
leather seats to a classic steering
wheel from Nardi a classic 1960s style
dashboard featuring a speedometer rev
counter fuel water oil and oil pressure
gauges plus the model has a five-speed
transmission which means it's a smooth
ride this fall comfo sucks this is the
heart of the Dino the engine the 2-liter
160 horsepower unit it has three double
pump carburetors a pretty big
accomplishment back then the name of the
car is taken from the engine that for
Dino Ferrari commissioned he's the son
of Enzo Ferrari used it for the Dino and
Fiat for its own version of the model
today there are very few Dino spiders
and good Nick there were originally 525
but no one really knows how many are
left today it's a huge collector's item
the spider is best at high speed but
it's a comfy ride over long distances
too
of course the Dino performs best on
country roads where you can really put
it to work that's a bunch of fun you can
go a bit quicker you can try to hit
maximum speed because the Dino feels
pretty spiffy between six and seven
thousand revs and the Dino sumptuous
engine is legendary
Michel didn't find it easy to part with
Dino it's a great car and delivers pure
driving pleasure and it makes him think
back to good times and places so it's
been tough saying goodbye that's Viki
it's offended but at least Michele knows
that - Dino will find a good home